foreign
this is from actually from your website
so this story in the war I've read about
the afternoon and I finally finally
finished my first novel manuscript
that's good and then here's a word I
always have trouble saying after failing
ignominously am I getting that oh I
always screw that up in numerous
attempts over the previous 10 years I
was living in a little town in northern
California then I tried it down the
street to my friend and Mentor Paul Rank
and told him the triumphant news good
for you he said without looking up start
the next one tomorrow
so why did he say that that's another
great question I'm absolutely a believer
in this you know sometimes
people will ask me what do you do
between books yeah you know and my
answer to that is there should never be
a between books
Seth Godin calls it the dip right if I
understand it right like the worst thing
a writer or a filmmaker or anybody can
do I'm sure you know this Tim it's like
finish something put it out there and
then sort of wait for the world to
respond right because they're either not
going to respond at all or they're going
to hate it right and meanwhile you're
sitting there you know driving yourself
insane so I'm definitely a believer that
by the time I finish one book well let's
we put a different way as I'm coming
towards say the last six months on a
book I want to be starting the next book
simultaneously even it's only notes you
know so that when I do like Paul ring
said to me start the next one tomorrow
you know or today because it's so hard
to do that and resistance is so hard you
got to just keep going so like people
will sometimes ask me to when do you
take a vacation when do you take a break
and the answer to that is
let's say I'm finishing one book okay I
kind of get get another one sort of
started so that when on Tuesday when I
finish that book Wednesday I plunge into
the next one and I'll go long enough so
I have a kind of a beachhead or I sort
of know I've got the troops are on the
beach yeah and there's enough momentum
that if I stop for a week or two weeks
I'll be able to pick it up again that's
when I'll take a vacation not in between
because it's so hard to get so Paul rink
was a mentor to me I used to have coffee
with him every morning when I was trying
to finish my first book I would be you
know I was you know just totally focused
and was he a writer what was he was a
writer he died a while ago he was like
maybe 30 years older than me and
um he lived in a camper and a pickup out
in front of his little house of his and
we would have coffee in his little
camper every morning and he sort of had
taken me under his wing sorry stupid
question but what if you had a house why
was he living in his camper he liked the
camper what can I say okay no he just he
would go in the house to pee that was it
but he sort of took me under his wing
and and um would tell me books to read
and sort of uh just give me sort of the
writers psyching you up yeah talk each
morning you know what type of advice did
you find helpful I mean I know this is a
while ago but were there any particular
pieces of advice aside from the start
the next one tomorrow
or any particular books you recommended
anything come to mind in in terms of
lessons that you either picked up
explicitly from him
or things that you absorbed I mean he
certainly gave me
many many books that I had to read you
know he sort of really had me read the
Canon you know tall story Dostoyevsky
you know all of those things you know
where he would just say to me you've got
to read you got to know this right you
can't be a writer and not know this you
know but the other thing was that he
really
he really believed in fiction writing as
a calling you know it wasn't for money
it wasn't for [ __ ] it was he really
made you feel like uh this was important
to the planet you know and that when you
sat down and do your work
you got to do it the best you absolutely
can and the other thing he said to me
that really helped sort of help me
evolve the idea of resistance was
that it's a war you know and that you've
got to be in there every day going after
it you know this is not
a part-time occupation or a weekend
warrior kind of situation that it's a
war and you got to do it so that was
great to me at that very early stage of
trying to formulate my own
ethic
coupled with that dream about ambition
you can see how to sort of those two
things are
as you as you're evolving as a young
writer those really go into your head
and help so
number five questions the first would be
why why did he or why do you feel like
fiction writing as a calling is
important to the planet is it because
you are and each person is endowed with
certain gifts and it's your obligation
to share those gifts is it because for
instance I happen to believe this that
truths can be transmitted sometimes much
more effectively in fiction than in any
non-fiction definitely
why is it important you know well let me
back up a little bit here Tim on that at
the time
I didn't think that at the time I was
just trying to survive like at this
particular time when I knew Paul rank
I had already written one novel all the
way through and then quit at the last
minute blew up my marriage blah blah
blah my whole life so at this particular
point where I was in I was working on it
the second one and my objective was just
to finish this [ __ ] you know I
didn't have any grander yeah even to
sell it forget it I didn't even think
about it and so people have contacts the
first one when you stopped it 100 feet
from the finish line
that was I assume a form of
self-sabotage but how did you how did
you justify it to yourself at the time I
didn't it was a catastrophe to me you
know a total failure like losing the
Super Bowl by fumbling on the one yard
finish this thing I don't know how to
finish it I mean is that the internal
voice at the time the voice was
Steve you were an idiot to even try to
write a book you don't know anything
about this you're not prepared mentally
you've had no training this is beyond
you it's like taking a tab of acid that
was that big you can't handle it you
know you are a loser you are a bum don't
ever do this again you know you went
down one road you've totally flamed out
boom you just kind of press the Looney
Tunes exactly that Nation on your life
exactly so then we Flash Forward to Paul
we're like I just want to finish this
[ __ ] thing to prove to myself that I
can finish it exactly and also to prove
to my ex-wife yeah because she thought I
was you know God knows what she thought
yeah but I wanted to prove to her even
though that was silly I mean that's a
useful fodder then of course I mean you
got to use what you can so all I was
trying to do was sort of get to the end
of a project and just say I'd finished
it
and
what happened for our people here
I did finish it and for the rest of my
life I've never had any trouble
finishing anything
whereas I couldn't finish anything
before so that really meant something
when you finished it because I'll be
honest in my case I go through recurrent
bouts of
finishing and not finishing so I haven't
had this
phase shift although I think I complete
more things and I don't if they're worth
completing I would say you do definitely
the stuff that I don't finish no one
ever sees right so they get this
highlight reel of the things that have
been completed
what changed for you and was it
immediate as soon as you finished you're
like I am now a person who finishes
things or I am a person who finishes
things how did it show up as a voice
that if it did help you then
in future projects
it did again it was like the dream about
ambition it did kick in right then and I
knew it you know I was writing on a
typewriter then this was pre-computers
so when you finish you roll the page out
of the typewriter and you have a stack
of pages you put the last page on it
says the end you know and in those days
I had carbon paper because you had to
have a copy right that you couldn't just
copy something so I really felt like you
know that's that's it I did it you know
I didn't know that I could I would never
have trouble because you don't know the
future but it did feel like yeah I did
something that I couldn't do before yep
and that's that yeah I've proven it to
myself I have that counter example of
finishing